[Music]
I took a page out of your favorite book
you saw me last just by the way you look
T me a language that I never speak baby
that ain't for me that that ain't for me
I dug my grave watching where you move
you took me higher than I ever flew too
many times gave you a second chance baby
I'm just a man I'm I'm just a man no for
thinking about you late night no for
running around with your friends now I'm
picking the pieces of my soul about the
floor
oh I said I would die for you
baby but I can't take this
ble I thought I was willing but tonight
I save my life when I showed you the
door I don't want to lose you
baby but I can't play this game no more
I thought it would kill me but tonight I
save my life when I show you the door
you never thought this day would ever
come when I looked you in the eyes and
pull the up you try to take away my
sanity baby that ain't for me that that
ain't for me oh no we thinking about you
late night no we running around with
your friends now the picking the pieces
of my soul come out the floor
oh I said I would die for your
Babor but I can't take this pain go more
I thought I was willing but tonight I
save my life when I showed you to go I
don't want to lose you
baby but I can't play this game no more
I thought it would kill me but tonight I
save my life when I show show you the
door when I show you the
door but tonight I sa my
life I said I would die for you
baby but I can't take this pain no more
I thought I was willing but tonight I
save my life when I show told you to
door I don't want to lose you baby to
lose you but I can't take this game no
more I thought it would kill me but
tonight I save my life when I showed you
the door
[Music]
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that flow
session goodness only knows I really
enjoyed performing it uh real quickly if
you are interested in grabbing a set of
those or poy Pros that I was using in
this video
you can do so and get 5% off when you
use the code Drex factor with a zero
instead of an O at checkout over at
ultra.com once again that is Drex factor
with a zero instead of an O and thank
you so much to ultra for sponsoring this
video speaking of thank yous uh big
thanks go out to the Friends of the
channel that is big thanks to dark monk
flow fests flow toys pyro ter light toys
and Ultra poy for helping them make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about these amazing companies
by checking out the links that I have
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- bus
friend of the channel That is Becca
Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission and finally this video and all
the videos on this channel would not be
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I'd love to
give a shout out to my flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now thank you
y all rock and if you out there watching
are interested in becoming supporters
and you're not supporters already you
can sign up to my patreon by heading
over to
patreon.com factor poo and signing up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you're interested and checking out more
of my flow sessions and performances I
will go ahead and include a playlist
link to those videos down in the
description as well as up on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow yourselves today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace